all right guys
bang bang lunch money time as you can
hear we have uh audience today it's fine
uh i actually don't know what state i'm
in um we are somewhere outside of new
york city
in what state massachusetts we're
massachusetts uh
some of you may know where that is on
the map most of you probably don't
that's fine
that's what google is for uh while
washington's trying to get registrations
trying to get a lunch money right
i'm here with pelina ivalova marinova
pompliano p-i-m-p
uh she's got and just so you guys if you
thought i was joking
literally there's a live audience
they're fine some will call them critics
some will call them fans
some will just call them friends friends
that's all good we just went to the
grocery store bought a lot of food
okay can you just do the sponsor thank
you uh oh the sponsor is block five
block five has three products
uh you can buy and sell crypto on the
crypto exchange or you can deposit
crypto take out a us dollar loan against
your crypto collateral
or my favorite product as an investor
and a user
is to deposit crypto and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account
go do it you earn three to five basis
points in your traditional account here
you earn 860 basis points
it's just math get money get paid block
five dot com slash lunch money
block five dot com slash lunch money all
right
we already tried to take this one time
and i said something that was
that was deemed inappropriate okay so
we're gonna try again i'm gonna be on my
best behavior thank you
so walmart it says it's teaming up with
microsoft in a bid for
tick-tock
so now i guess people are going to be
twerking for walmart on tick-tock
i said something else the first take and
i got yelled at so now that was my pg
version nobody's twerking
uh literally the whop you guys think
that i'm old you think i don't know
what's going on on tick-tock
i'm all over that stuff i know exactly
what's going on
right is that how you pronounce it can
you explain what that means no
the other day i asked paulina what it
meant and she she was like i don't know
i don't know and i sat and i thought for
like five minutes
and i figured it out myself i didn't
have to look up anything
i've been on the streets i know culture
go ahead
so what's up with why does walmart want
to buy this exactly that was my question
well you're the uh tech analyst here
well uh there's
they're they're i don't know walmart's
walmart is trying to acquire the tech
with oracle
yeah i think walmart's trying to compete
with amazon that's always my answer
if you guys ever wanted to know what
polina looks like when she shook this is
it can you can you stop shaking the
table thank you um
so walmart so the walmart plans to
launch a membership program called
walmart plus so maybe it'll be able to
include tick tock in the video section
uh i don't think that that makes a lot
of sense what do you guys think
i think it says a lot about who the tick
tock down graphic is
interested ooh great piece of feedback
uh from the unnamed source in the crowd
they said that uh the fact that walmart
wants to acquire
it speaks a lot about the demographic
that's on tick-tock
what else anything else from the peanut
gallery
they're all very shy all of a sudden
everyone had a lot of opinions until uh
the lights and cameras go on okay stop
walmart's never been in the content game
so i don't understand ooh walmart's
never been the content game
true is it easier to create content as a
netflix full-length movies or just to do
user-generated content at walmart that's
out of tick-tock
it's probably easier just to let
everybody else do the content so
somebody said when you need it is it
because this is going to be deleting
like walmart prime like are they trying
to like
they're like amazon uses content like
they're going to leave for amazon
but are they going to put tick tock
behind the paywall well i think it makes
a lot more sense because tick tock might
have
that 200 million dollar fund where
they're trying to um pay for content
and they're the first ugc business to
like actually start like taking a stand
that we're going to pay for exclusive
content
so if that's already part of the road
map that 200 million dollar fund of it
becomes like a two billion dollar fund
and then what happened to the streaming
wars across amazon
netflix et cetera ends up being
happening with social wars because then
tick tock when that's a two million
dollar fund so amazon will do a four
billion dollar fund for instant creators
so so just in case you guys
didn't hear that that's one of our smart
friends that one right there
but true very true please okay well i'm
spinning my phone on the table and it's
annoying playing us because it's shaking
the camera
okay okay so well when you look as ugly
as me sometimes you need a little shake
to just get things looking good
go ahead what's up with the warby parker
you're twerking on my nerves
warby parker the optical e-commerce
giant
aka they make glasses we're gonna have a
conversation has today announced
not today yesterday yesterday announced
the close of a 245 million dollar
funding round
from d1 capital partners durable capital
partners t row price and bailey gifford
and its valuation is now 3 billion
dollars
if you're blind you'll pay whatever for
glasses but you're not even if you're
blind also
i know they actually no they actually do
a lot of non-prescription glasses i
think like they basically made it cool
like cool types of glasses whether
they're prescription or not sunglasses
whatever
uh it's 10 years ago and they've pivoted
a few times they started with
prescription
yeah and the whole idea was basically
they could do it for 100
or less per frame and so uh i'm sure
many of you have used warby parker
before
if you have please leave a comment i'll
uh go and check out your awesome glasses
you can even leave a little photo with
your glasses
that's fine just link me to your twitter
account where the photo is or maybe you
have an instagram
it's fine i'll go do some ratings i'll
leave you a little rating on the uh
on the photo so yeah so i think that's
interesting i don't think i don't know
if
you think it's about you think it's do
you remember on
uh uh jeopardy when they'd be like daily
double
sure that's what just happened hey guys
listen this is our friend dustin
right there dustin owns a wine business
if you guys go and buy wine
at verve wine he'll do nothing for you
other than send you the wine it's an
amazing deal
you go to the website you plug in your
information you can buy one do the ship
everywhere in the u.s it's called
verve wine so pretty much unless you
live in a weird place they'll ship you
wine it's fanta
it's the best wine you literally once
you drink this wine you won't need any
other wine in the world
uh vervewine.com correct verve wine
w i n v-e-r-v-e-w-i-n-e dot com now the
reason why you should buy this wine like
daily double style
is because dustin is one of 200
one of 250 master sommeliers in the
world
so for those of you that don't know what
that means go google it it basically
means you're an expert at wine
last night he pulled out a bottle and he
showed it to us and i said what is that
and he started talking i said okay it's
red wine got it and then we drink it
so verve wine verve wine.com okay ready
go to your podcast with him
oh yeah we did a podcast together where
he tells all the secrets
also great recommendation just like the
last book i told you guys about
go watch sour grapes sour what i say
sourd whatever you guys know you guys
already know how i talk about it okay
apple verve wine.com apple rejects
facebook app that tells users that apple
takes 30
cut of in-app purchases so basically
facebook had a new app update that tried
to inform users that apple collects 30
percent of in-app
purchases from some online events
feature and then apple
projected it i like apple apple they're
very nice people
i hope that they continue to work very
nicely with everyone in the app store
i'm not playing around with apple you
guys are awesome thank you so much for
the great service you provide
facebook uh guys i promise nobody is
drunk here
the last headline i need is idiot says
something bad apple takes app out of the
app store
what app do you have on that no
literally that's the worst part is i'm
not worried about any of my apps
so facebook but facebook asked apple to
reduce its 30 app store cut since it
wanted all the money to go directly to
small businesses
but apple rejected that that sucks i
mean apple look the monopoly is over
the writing's on the wall they may be
able to extend this out for a couple
more
uh months maybe even a year or two but i
just don't see a world where
regulators are going to allow this to
continue uh
and also as we've previously discussed
many times
apple is going to have a hard time
defending the fact that they give
everyone the same deal
when it's very clear that amazon's
amazon prime video app
allows for credit card processing
through amazon's payment system not
apples
and also companies like netflix etc can
send you around
the app store amazon's app does apple
take a cut from amazon's app
i do not know i do not speculate on
anything i think apple does a fantastic
job of what they do they provide a great
service by providing so many users
is this how you talk about me when i'm
not in the room paulina is amazing you
should see how happy i am without
when i am with her great thank you um
so okay so 3d printing could change the
way that our homes are built
um basically uh 3d printing is an
area that has generated a great deal of
interest over the last few years
and right now the technology is rapidly
developing and a number of projects are
being
built so there's a house in belgium
that was 3d printed this summer is that
cool i saw the video
oh really yeah it's pretty cool it's 48
hours i think
yeah it took just 48 hours for the
structure to be printed as well as
enabling a rapid construction process
the use of 3d printing
also cuts waste see what i told you kids
if you don't do drugs you don't drink
and you read the internet
you can remember things don't worry okay
so so that's cool so what does that mean
for the
you know real estate actually i think 3d
manufacturing is going to have a huge
resurgence because
uh the economy has optimized for
efficiency over resiliency and they put
all the manufacturing and supply chains
all around the world but covid reminded
everyone that maybe it might be a good
idea if we could bring some stuff back
to the us and do it here
but the problem is that the labor costs
are too high and so they're going to
look to technology and so what's
one of the best ways that you can do
around manufacturing is 3d manufacturing
automation etc
i'm still spinning the phone he's still
very happy okay very happy
anybody have any ideas would you guys
live in a 3d printed home yeah our
friend kayla
are most homes built from wood so like
what are they're printing
different pieces of it so it's all going
to classify yeah what's the material
oh ah she's all for games
she acts out of the article see ladies
and gentlemen and we don't have internet
out here so she's really messed up i
know i got it i got it
what is it basically you know um today's
concrete right
no you're calling me 3d printing oh yeah
it is a
concrete wall printed by kids if you
don't do drugs you don't drink and you
read the internet i promise you'll
remember
stuff so they're printing concrete
somehow it blows my mind
no what i think that they're doing is
that i believe that the way the 3d
printer works is
it basically takes the ingredients right
and it creates concrete as part of the
machine and then what it's doing is
uh the machine is laying it in a
specific way
[Music]
up yeah so what do we think healing
oh my doctor stop
doxing people it seems a little
it seems a little like inefficient
inefficient like where are you gonna
like where are you gonna do it in a city
then like there's gonna be like a whole
like how do you bring all the
3d printing materials there the printer
what if they did a whole uh
skyscraper that'd be wild oh that's even
yours out yeah okay we're not convinced
that jetsons are here yet
uh would you live in a 3d printed
skyscraper if you were the first person
to move in
i would want to work on it uh the
the robot is architect okay speaking of
technology
okay mr musk so he has this company
called neuralink basically it tries to
merge the brain with the computers and
the ai all that stuff
brain machine interface for all of you
keeping track at home yes
brain machine i think it's machine no
it's brain
brain computer interface so you can
he has he's showing off the latest
developments
uh friday august 28th at 3 p.m pacific
6 p.m eastern so 6 p.m eastern today
not today oh today i don't know what day
it is
today musk will be showing off the
latest
use case how we can connect our brains
with pcs so since he's such a great
marketer do you think that he's now
going to start
including in the press releases fourth
richest person
unveils brain computer interface
you know he's the fourth richest person
in the world right now yeah on paper
yeah yeah do you think that bezos or him
reaches a trillion first
bases really not if walmart buys tick
tock not if walmart buys dick duck
what if i lost his satoshi
hey we have another friend that they're
speaking now she's going on a call
we have another friend
she hasn't got guys she has a call i
feel like maybe we should just do a live
stream with all of our friends and we
can just
all right so i like this story are you
are you gonna be quiet
okay hold on so um this is definitely
the best episode yeah
hey you guys better make this episode go
viral all right
so tom cruise is filming in poland and
he is
pissed because his crew from mission
impossible like 85
wants to blow up a bridge in poland and
all the people in poland in this little
you know city you're like okay well this
is a historic bridge like we're not
going to just let you blow up
cruises hold on and listen to this
listen to this local video blogger what
he said
this particular bridge is an
extraordinary monument it is the highest
train bridge in poland
let's say the most famous european movie
director wanted to shoot a super famous
movie in new york
and for the purpose of this film he
needed to blow up the head of the statue
of liberty would americans say okay cool
this is how we're going to promote our
culture in europe
it's like that's a little bit of an
extreme well i have one question
it's a really old bridge it needed
renovation anyway
shouldn't there be another description
for your job instead of local video
blogger like aren't you just a
videographer
well unclear okay so basically i thought
tom cruise you were claiming that he was
going to space
he is going to space he's not going to
he's going to space he's not going to go
to space
okay nasa said they weren't here our
friends weren't here when i called him
an old [ __ ]
yes he's fine yeah see
he's very short thank you see there's
people going to go to space
by the way i like tom cruise top gun so
what do you think about blowing up this
bridge do you think they should let him
do it
i don't have the first information i
don't know i'm not polish
i need to repair it afterwards should we
take a vote yeah
we're gonna vote uh hold on we'll take a
vote uh in favor of blowing up the
bridge
uh all five people raise their hand
all right so this is the tom cruise
wanna blow the bridge he does
i'm definitely against it
kind of feels like a scientology thing i
think that he shouldn't do it okay
[Applause]
is fascinated by scientology in north
korea
um guys can we now we're going to end up
on a list
guys should we do this all together just
what is the next
topic the next topic is there's a
landmark
study that shows that relationships i
have to go to the bathroom
no this is good for you it doesn't
matter who you pick as your partner
they found out it matters what your
dynamic is
more than the personality of your
partner do you buy that
i don't understand what they're saying
they're basically saying like your own
judgment of your relationship meaning
how satisfied you are you
you feel your partner is for help oh my
god
there was just two uh kamikaze birds
that flew into the window
um so yeah so that wasn't a bad
relationship there yeah
that bad relationship and burden in
other words don't focus so much on
whether
a person fits your type or whether they
check all your boxes and said think
about how you're engaging with each
other and whether your relationship
leaves you feeling satisfied
paulina is fantastic she is literally
the best
and that's it
so i mean i i i think that's fair so can
i uh
rephrase this amazingly articulated
article into just
if you're happy you're happy yeah but
some people don't know if they're happy
they're like very like finicky
i think a lot of academic studies maybe
don't need to actually happen
huh go ahead with your joke by the way
there's actually a real crowd here so
we'll see what's funny and what's next
are you guys ready for my joke why is
sunday
stronger than monday
yeah people are already laughing that's
how bad the audience is they're already
laughing
the joke hasn't even happened yet why
any guesses monday is a weekday
[Applause]
[Music]
i love this video audience i love
thank you guys make sure that you have
great friends
they're supportive whether you're fast
or not whether you're athletic or not
smart or not funny or not they just
always say great job
it's like a relationship that's how i
know i'm satisfied in my relationship
i i promise we're not paying anyone go
buy wine at vervewine.com
you can go to blockfy.com lunch money
and buy cryptocurrencies
or you can go sign
[Music]
go ahead you could show stuff that's
fine you didn't pay for this but go
ahead
this is this is uh uh what is it
unprofitable ad for us
are you gonna tell them what the site is
read the profile.com
what happens there oh a lot of stuff
happens there
um the best things in life happen there
what what what happens people can read
about interesting people
amazing pitch anthony hasn't gotten
profiled on there yet he's a little
bitter
yeah i don't need actually i think we
just talked about this before
uh for the first like three months that
plane and i were dating my brothers were
convinced that pluto was going to write
a hit like a hit on me
they literally were like stop like
hanging out with that girl she's
definitely like writing a story on you
and i was like definitely still writing
the story yeah could you imagine
i got the red line like that
that dude is so dumb let me tell you
about the time
oh oh yeah all right
all right guys guys i really hope you
have a better weekend than maybe
what a dumpster all right guys that's it
while watching trying to get rich for us
just trying to get lunch money right see
you on monday
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends